China has released a new white paper on
national defense its first in four years
the document lays out the country's
military preparedness and security
strategy it turns out that one of
Beijing's top concerns is somewhat
domestic officials worried about
separatist movements in Tibet and
Xinjiang in the Far West and the paper
goes on to warn Taiwan a de facto
functionally independent separate
country from declaring formal
independence China also singled out the
United States Japan and Australia as
players bringing security uncertainties
to the Pacific region and also pledged
to respond if it was ever attacked
adding that its own military does not
pose a threat the building and growth of
China's defense capability is based on
its own justified security demands its
growth has always been the growth of the
force for world peace the white paper
has clearly demonstrated China's policy
of not pursuing hegemony the theory that
a strong country must seek hegemony will
never apply to China no matter how
China's developed in the future we will
not threaten anyone neither will we seek
spheres of influence
butyou'll so China's saying essentially
it's peaceful the problem is everybody
else
Adham me a security expert at Macquarie
University in Australia joins us now for
more my first thought is those countries
seeing China build out those military
spaces in the South China Sea
they're not exactly buying into the
pitch that this is a peaceful arise are
they well Melissa China went to great
lengths in this white paper to explain
why it's military modernization is
peaceful and that has no intention of
threatening any other countries but
whatever its intent or rhetoric its
actions speak the loudest and regional
countries are increasingly anxious about
Chinese high power so the militarization
of the South China Sea its belligerent
towards Taiwan its encroachment on civil
liberties in Hong Kong and human rights
abuses in King John and the general way
in which has become more repressive
internally and more assertive
internationally under Xi Jinping these
actions
are creating real anxieties both within
China as well as in China's neighborhood
and beyond what else struck you about
the white paper well I think there are
three things that really struck me the
first thing is antagonism towards the
United States
the white paper characterizes the United
States as a force that's trying to keep
China down or at least it implies that
and the stabilize China's neighborhood
so of course it doesn't acknowledge that
China's own role in raising some of the
anxieties and destabilizing factors but
China sees the United States as a
country that it confronts in the region
and a real security challenge but seeing
this explicitly in this high profile
strategic and policy document is
certainly important and speaks volume
the other two things are the white
papers focus on political loyalty of the
armed forces above all else as well as
the internal focus of China's military
so in terms of maintaining domestic
stability but also the political power
of the Communist Party how do you think
the overall region of Asia the Asia
Pacific is going to react to this white
paper I think very much so in terms of
strategy there's nothing really new in
this paper a lot of the details of the
strategy what China is doing originally
as well as in terms of its military
modernization is known at least to DRD
experts and the policy makers but what I
think is new is the new assertive
confident tone and the political
rhetoric that accompanies it
Adam nee thank you very much